we begin with breaking news a prominent
Palestinian activist Carter Adnan has
died in an Israeli prison after 86 days
on Hunger Strike Adnan was a member of
Islamic Jihad he was arrested by Israeli
forces near his home in Janine in early
February and had been on Hunger Strike
to protest against the conditions of his
detention Carter Adnan was 45 but
Mustafa bar duties from the Palestinian
national initiative he called adnan's
Death an act of assassination by the
Israeli government
this is a very dangerous uh thing that
has happened the Israeli government and
in particular being weird this fascist
who is a minister in the Israeli
government are personally responsible
for this act of assassination I call it
an act of assassination because the
Israeli government knew very well and
its military courts that a person who is
on hunger strike for 87 days who did not
receive any kind of Medical Care could
die at any moment and that's exactly
what has happened is a political
activist he was not engaged or involved
in any kind of military action for
instance he was just politically
resisting occupation with his speeches
with his talks with his
solidarity actions he is a political
activist
and he was trying to express the
suffering of the Palestinian people and
demanding our freedom from occupation
and the system of apartheid that we are
subjected to but let me tell you that
the conditions in which Palestinian
prisoners are kept is horrible we have
lost up till this moment
337 Palestinian prisoners who died in
Israeli jail
Israel issued no less than 13
000 order of administrative detention
without charges against Palestinians and
as I said there are one thousand of them
today at this moment including six
children under administrative detention
this is a country that is practicing
fascism it is a country Israel is a
country that is practicing
unacceptable violation of Human Rights
while Al jazeera's neither Ibrahim is on
the line from Ramallah in the occupied
West Bank neither so what more can you
tell us about Carter Adnan and the
events leading up to his death
this is the fifth strike for hazratman
in Israeli jails it was the longest
before he was found unconscious in his
cell and taken to a hospital in Israel
before he was announced that there were
many warnings from his family saying
that his health is deteriorating he
started the hunger strike in February as
soon as he was arrested because he was
expecting that he will be held without
charges as it has been the case with him
many times this is a person who has
spent eight years in Israeli jails then
he was presented with a list of charges
that he said were disproportionate to
the sentence and the years that were
requested for him so he continued his
hunger strike many human rights
organizations were saying that they
needed there needed to be efforts to
save him and unfortunately he died this
morning in himself Anita is his death
likely to lead to an escalation in
violence perhaps across the West Bank
well when you talk to Palestinians they
will tell you that this is an effort by
Israel to kill Israeli and sorry
Palestinian prisoners who are undergoing
hunger strike them in particular is a
symbol for that he in 2012 started the
movement let's call it of individual
hunger strikes uh protesting arrest
without charges and while this case is
different still he's a very symbolic
person we've heard from Palestinian
officials the Prime Minister calling it
an act of assassination the Palestinian
uh the PLO Secretary General saying that
Israel holds all accountability for his
death we heard from Islamic Jihad saying
that this is an escalation and that they
will respond to so it's hard to tell how
it's gonna play out but it's already
sense in the respect we're hearing
report of a shooting near an illegal
Israeli settlement uh with hearing
potentially
the stabbing attack we're following the
news of course this is a Sentimental
issue he's a symbolic triggered but it
remains to be seen how it's going to be
playing out here in the occupied West
Bank all right Anita Ibraham live first
there in Ramallah in the occupied West
Bank Anita thank you well there have
been attacks from Gaza towards Israel
side is live now on the phone from Gaza
City you know what sort of response have
we seen and heard in Gaza to the death
of kada Adnan
yes so uh policy infections here in the
Gaza Strip Islamic Jihad Hamas and all
other Palestinian factions they've
mourned uh and they said that they hold
the Israel occupation full
responsibility for this uh uh genius
crime that has been committed against
also here Palestinian factions uh have
vowed for a response on this Israeli
crime and they have called out for a
general strike and protest among the
different cities of because this trip
also a morning Trent and uh and and and
a press conference shall be held in the
central uh Gaza Square in about at 8G
and that means that the policy
infections have also said that in this
conference they will be announcing a
list of uh a list of bringings or
findings that they have uh uh agreed to
after the killing of radnan all right
they're live for some Gaza City you're
not thank you